[Music]
welcome
i'm mitch president rafael reif and i'm
delighted to introduce this celebration
of the 2020 eugene mcdermott award in
the arts at mit
and this year's recipient designer
thomas heatherwick
we will learn more about his work and
his vision in a few moments
but first a few messages of things
to the council for the arts at mit for
all you do
to bring the arts to life at mit we can
never
thank you enough and to marry mcdermott
cook
continuing the legacy of eugene
mcdermott your enduring support
is our inspiration thank you
this year we have had to reinvent our
traditions to fit into a digital
format and i know we're all disappointed
that we cannot gather in celebration of
the arts at
mit but the mcdermott award endures
as a powerful reminder that the arts are
central to mit's mission
and absolutely critical to the growth
and fulfillment
of our students the study of art
and design crosses disciplines forges
new connections
and grounds tomorrow's technologies in
humanity's
deepest values this year's award winner
thomas hetherweek
has gained international acclaim for
creating objects
and spaces that delight the public and
bring
people together personally
my favorite part of the mcdermott award
because it reflects mit's hands-on
spirit
is the artist's residency and of course
in this most unusual year we had a most
unusual residency thomas hetherweek had
issued a design
challenge to the students in 40222 the
spring 2020 design studio
and that is to create a public space
where people want to go
even though in our digital world they no
longer need to
this charge was then flipped on its head
by the current pandemic
suddenly we were being actively
discouraged from going to public spaces
and would turn even more to digital
forms of connection
i know you will enjoy learning about the
unexpected journey inspired by this
year's
mcdermott award
the world when you mention mit says of
course the world's greatest university
for science and technology
we love hearing that we hope it's true
but it's much more than science and
technology
science and technology in dialogue with
all other discipline
and the arts perhaps fit more cleanly
into that world of science and
technology than any other
because they are about creativity
they're about discovery
they're about innovation they're about
problem solving and that's what's great
science and
engineering is all about
the mcdermott prize in the arts at mit
is mit's most important most resonant
prize
in the arts it has a national and
international
visibility the council for the arts at
mit is a group of around
80 volunteers invited by the president
of the institute
to serve as ambassadors and arts
advocates
for all of the arts at mit the council
for the arts has presented the
eugene mcdermott award in the arts since
1974.
it's given the council for the arts
a real opportunity to have an impact
on the arts at mit
[Music]
and also has brought the community at
mit
and other arts leaders from around the
country to come to mit
to recognize the recipient and to
really afford the opportunity to see
really how
mit supports the arts but around 50
years or so ago
the president of mit set up a group the
council for the arts at mit
to help guide undergrad and graduate
student populations
in their education of arts and
humanities
and specifically to expose them to
things
that they wouldn't have access to that
would echo the same experimentation
from the science industry in experiments
of art
we need art to help us guide
experimentation and creative thinking
around how technologies might be applied
in more creative ways
mcdermott award recipients are united
in several ways they
are all individuals of great distinction
whose body of work indicates
that they will be leaders in their field
for years to come
they also represent and reflect mit's
commitment to
problem solving risk taking and bringing
creative minds together
in a multi-disciplinary way
margaret mcdermott created the mcdermott
award
in honor of her husband the late eugene
mcdermott she created this award to
honor his memory
but at the same time to promote the arts
the sixth arts institutions that the
mcdermott
gala support are the art culture and
technology
program
[Music]
and the department of architecture
our center for art science and
technology which
encompasses all of the arts
[Music]
our music and theater department
[Music]
this query that
[Music]
the is museum which is all about art
science and technology
[Music]
our list visual arts center which is all
about
defining and bringing to mit artists
having their work exhibited promoting
them and many go on to very stellar
careers
and it's the list visual arts center who
are responsible for the curation
of our public art collection
[Music]
thomas heatherwick is a great selection
for this year's eugene mcdermott
award in the arts at mit
thomas heatherwick is a world-class
designer
working at the forefront of new
materials
and he's constantly pushing the edge on
how to make it better
and he's most well known recently for
his vessel
project in new york
i feel that he brings a sensitivity to
human interaction
with the objects and their scale that
i've not seen
with other designers he also really
delves deep into the balance between
simplicity
and technology needed for the execution
of these objects
they are extremely interesting pieces
and controversial enough to generate
a lot of conversation the recipient of
the mcdermott award in any given year
gets quite a bit out of that award the
recipient receives a hundred thousand
dollar cash prize
they are also granted a residency
which is framed to fit their unique
style and schedule
they get access to the entire mit
faculty and student community
to engage to really be at the forefront
of
technology research as it applies to
their respective industries
when we announced him as the new prize
winner for 2020
we worked with him to define a subject
for his residency he picked
a remarkable theme hyper physicality
as an antidote to the spreading world of
the digital world
of hyper digitality
i've got very interested in the notion
of hyper physicality
that's come about in a sense
because the
advent of the digital revolution has
meant that there's been a
big thrust towards the virtual
and the non-physical the world is
conspiring to keep you in
your house and keep you at home and keep
with that a sense of isolation and
the exciting thing for us as designers
in the very physical realm is that
places now need to mean more to you in
order
to tip you from staying inside to
thinking
actually i'll go somewhere for something
to drink or
go to see someone or to meet someone or
to
all the millions of things that public
life triggers how's
everyone doing who would have thought
that the subject of hyperphysicality
would be so
relevant because we're having to
socially distance
but i actually feel socially closer
to more people i'm closer to you now
because i don't know if
that's your kitchen you'd have never
shown me your kitchen if we
were meeting now in boston
[Music]
students usually embark on a large-scale
building exercise
where they build pavilions that are 15
feet or more in dimension
it's been i think a little bit difficult
because in the middle of this project
everyone had to leave campus
go to their individual homes and sort of
find what they could produce essentially
in their kitchens
when we originally set this theme of
hyperphysicality the context was
completely different
the world was okay and i think
thomas and i were looking forward to
meeting you all in person and having
physical engaging discussions about
hyperphysicality
and then the world changed the students
are looking at physical means of
connection that are
able to bridge between their various
environments
expanding beyond that initial definition
of hyper
whether that's through light sound
touch smell orientation or movement
[Music]
we've been interested in how you make
places engage people more our research
in our studio
is how do you bring people together why
would you go somewhere
when you don't need to unless it really
connects with your
humanity in some way and engages you
i took hyperphysicality to mean creating
some sort of shared experience we had to
find a way
to merge the physical
and digital world it was very vague but
it became very interesting because
of this whole coronavare situation
the students jumped in and
embraced the sudden shift in the
in the whole project and yet it was so
relevant
and it was a treat for us to watch
process happen over a number of weeks
so this is a giant tessellating
structure that would act as an acoustic
sound drop
an acoustic backdrop is hyper physical
because
it creates a more immersive experience
my project was basically trying to
create some sort of object that you
could
take into a video call in order to make
that call a more playful environment
and to sort of have time with your
friends that was
not limited to just this box that we're
in all the time now
our group wanted to focus on obsessive
rituals
in particular uh in light of this kobe
19 situation
hand washing and we saw it as hyper
physical because
soap is one of the only things that we
can all physically touch right now and
kind of share so you can see all of
these
five blocks that we've been using for
about three weeks now
when we wash our hands and you can see
how over time each person's has eroded
to emphasize different motions it's a
lovely project
i i love the materials you've used i
find them still
holding back a little bit in in terms of
form
i would push it to its limit until they
are
the definitive hand sculptural
the dance i mean there's a choreography
that we've really
tracked which was lovely um and
how you can they provoke that that hand
dance
i think it's really powerful to have
people
involved in classes that are doing what
you want
to do when you graduate see kind of
what you're going towards
i really appreciate the amount of
efforts and
deep thinking that each of you have put
into this because i know
it's an incredibly abstract brief
dissecting the word hyper
and turn it into these incredibly
physical things
that yet operate in totally non-physical
ways in order to connect you
there wouldn't have been a better time
to be thinking about this idea of hyper
physicality
than when you're at home trying to
share your experience with other people
that aren't there with you
so you have to find creative ways to
express yourself and that was what this
class was about
i'm glad that all of you were able to
sort of
take i think the brief not just as
something to design for but as a
methodology as well
that gave you physical interactions that
forced you
to do physical things i feel like i got
to focus
more on building the narrative and
communication
in the studio i might have focused more
on
the tools seeing what i could do with
the tools rather than what the tools
could do
for me the wartime spirit was quite
amazing
because every student was working at
home
there was the immediacy of what do you
have around your house
maybe we had a more meaningful
interaction in some strange way by not
being together
because we were thrown together in the
adversity
of the situation
hello my name is hashem sarkis i'm the
dean of the school of architecture and
planning at
mit and i am here to interview
the recipient of the mcdermott award for
the arts
at mit for this year thomas heatherwick
giving the mcdermott award to a designer
this year
highlights the growing interest in
design at mit
as a new undergraduate major and minor
as a joint initiative across mit between
engineering and
architecture but also across the
institute
with management science and the
humanities
and importantly as a new
and growing frontier in research
giving the mcdermott to thomas
heatherwick specifically
celebrates a new direction for design
it is in some ways a return also to the
renaissance
to renaissance use of the term design as
a way
to draw out to draw out of the mundane
scenes of life
a sense of wonder and as a way to turn
everyday objects into dignified
monuments
for human experience
we are celebrating you after you have
spent time
with the mit faculty and students
so i hope you can reflect on your
experience here
it was an unusual one to be sure but
what distinguished it even further is
the theme
of hyper physicality that you chose for
your work with the students
can you please speak to that yeah well
uh
when we came up with that idea that
hyperphysicality
might be the thing that the students
might get their heads
around there hadn't been a global
pandemic
at that moment by not being together we
would have thought that it would have
been the worst
but it was it was really impressive
the the the students did i wonder if
they would have been that good
if they'd actually been together somehow
the adversity
meant the experimentation was
formidable and i enjoyed
not knowing what background the students
had i didn't know
who were who were mechanical engineers
who were architects
who were whatever i mean the mix of
courses and i didn't know if someone
came from humanities linguistics
biological engineering it didn't matter
there were groups
and they worked together without being
together
and the experimentation
using whatever people could find around
their homes
also was displaying a practical
intelligence
and um i i guess
i think i think the reason i'm sounding
so gushing is because i think i knew
that there was going to be
experimentation
i didn't know there'd be that much
experimentation and i did predict
there'd be
ideas but what i didn't predict is was
that there would be beauty
students did things that were beautiful
and that was
uh that was exciting to see because then
it became relevant to me it became 100
relevant it's like ideas without
thinking about
the emotional feeling of those ideas
to me has been part of the problem that
we've had for a long time and
we i it was a pleasure to see a maturity
of framing of ideas of understanding how
to
put them across even expert experiments
that the students were doing in
analytical um
diagrams and studies they framed them
beautifully i i actually felt like i was
reconnecting with the experimentation
that i was doing as
when i was at college which not many
people were doing
and especially a place as cerebral
as mit my day thomas
we take compliments about our students
anytime but
importantly what you said resonates very
strongly because
we try very hard we strive
not to teach but to encourage learning
and to learn with the students as well
and i feel like uh
hearing from you about your experience
we've achieved that with jeremy and with
yours
with your group
i mean here you are sitting in something
that looks like an orangery drawing room
but it's actually your desk and instead
of the plants being in the background of
that zoom window
you've brought them to the foreground
and background
you've turned your space into both
architecture
and garden
there is a long tradition of
associating the designed object with the
vegetable and with the animal
but that has become now increasingly
complicated by
this expanded understanding of
who we are where we are in relationship
to other beings
on this planet uh and also in
our understanding of
our impact on this planet as having been
negative for the most
part and that these creatures animals or
plants
are vulnerable because of us
i i i ask this question for at two
levels one in terms of
the traditional understanding of the
designed object as being an object that
takes on isomorphic and vegetal motifs
around it and even
morphologies and we begin to associate
the things we produce
with that drum as a kind of other world
than the human world
but also in relationship to the growing
ecological consciousness
which necessitates a very different
relationship with these objects
your work is deeply into that
and by deeply into that i mean it is
opening up possibilities in this domain
and i wanted to ask you if you could
speak to that dimension
in your work uh can you tell us about
the table
we were commissioned and and at the
beginning of the
lockdown phase and i think we were in
april
to design a desk and normally we would
have probably not
been that inspired to design a desk but
at that time
we were all suddenly finding some
scrambling
in in our all our different homes
to find places to work and the idea of a
study
or an office sounded so victorian and
many of us didn't even have proper
home work spaces and
me and uh two of my colleagues stuart
woods and tom glover were
thinking how can we make somewhere that
is a place you can sustain and sit at
for eight nine hours a day and uh
so we were just sitting and thinking
well if you're going to work
with that kind of amount of time
what would you like to sit and just
thought well a garden if you could sit
within a garden
last time i sat at a desk for
for eight nine hours at a time every day
every day every day was when i was 16
doing exams and that's and i disappeared
into the world of
designing things to get away from that
it's not a desk it's legs so each leg is
like a
um a g-clamp and but it's a
a leg that becomes a
planter it feels like you're in a
bonnard painting in a pierre bonnard
painting
but it also feels like you're inhabiting
the wallpaper in a drawing room or
if we bring it to contemporary
experiences
you know how people have a background in
their window
in their zoom window and sometimes when
they sit back a little bit they
disappear into that
yes it feels a bit like you're
disappearing in a fake
background of a landscape from somewhere
i promise you it's not a zoom background
it's real
in your work but also in your thinking
where do you think the next frontiers
lie
not just of your work but also of the
field
we see you as a kind of
forerunner someone that is seeking new
outlooks
not just for your own work but for the
field in general just walk down the
street and just you start seeing
problems
you just think why is that so bad why is
that so bad
why did that well and so for me
everything grows from
problems and and to me
i see a problem not as a negative thing
but as an incredibly
inspiring thing and then and as soon as
you saw a problem
just the seeing of the problem you're
half you're three quarters of the way to
solving that problem
i think the only time you stop having
ideas is if you think the world's
perfect
and i and i would be fascinated to find
anyone who thinks that um
my particular interest is in
uh more and more is in our
is in the public realm is how we all
come together
and it's kind of a cliche of cities that
the most artistic buildings are the arts
buildings
but they're the buildings that not
everyone goes into and not everyone has
to go into or needs to go into
for me the word culture is also misused
because to me
a culture isn't theaters and
art galleries and opera houses
culture is the culture of everything in
your life it's the wastes
waste depot it's the um
the unemployment uh office it's the
community centers that's the culture of
our life is all of those things
so i'd rather not compete you know and
i'd rather do something that
other people aren't making good so for
me it
the creativity of the commission
is the most important thing
there's a poverty in the english
language which is usually very rich
about these things
and expressing an aspect of what
we do as architects in the social
services world which is a word that
exists in french in
spanish which is equipment social
equipment
by that it means hospital schools
local libraries as you said unemployment
offices
and we call it social infrastructure
sometimes and somehow they call it
social equipment but what it is is
really
a dimension of our public realm that has
been
somehow relegated to the infrastructure
therefore becoming invisible
rather than being visible aestheticized
elevated dignified
and uh yes your work uh
highlights that dimension a recovering
a sense of wonder a sense of dignity
in the public in the everyday public
life
but also uh introducing uh
a kind of unexpected monumentality there
in the venice finale for 2021 i am
dedicating a very big section actually
the biggest section of the binary will
be dedicated to this
idea of reinventing the social equipment
you are going to be designing a project
for the binary that we cannot talk about
specifically
but maybe you can reflect on that
meaning
the setting of an artistic exhibition
and the work that you're doing within it
also as being a designer among
architects and they are not the same
breed
i think you've discovered that in many
contexts of operation
but more importantly by telling us
please how will we live together
i think that there is a joy to being
together
and the moments that we share that
i'm always looking in our projects
to amplify in a sense how do you break
people out of themselves i believe
design can do that
it's break us out of ourselves and and
actually that we
each have those yearnings and they're so
precious and now more than ever
that we will be maybe working from home
more of our time
cities don't need to imprison us just
like the workplace won't
have it have us in a headlock anymore
cities won't either
what are the what are the ways that make
people come together because that's the
thing that the digital revolution can't
do for you
and your home wherever it is can't
really do for you
and there is a magic and i do believe
that there is a power to humans together
as a group
we can we can solve problems in quite
extraordinary ways
but we can also have incredible social
interaction together and
and i see my job as making triggers
excuses
urban chemistries that make togetherness
happen
the only thing was i i wanted to say
really that um
i uh the amazing thing about this
this prize and the working with the
students
and this you know great honor for my
studio
has been also was also the idea that we
could
um come and be at mit and see you all
and
know you even better a mcdermott is an
overture it's it's not a closure
to the country and we really would
love to bring you back again and again
for more of these discussions for more
of your brilliance
right it's great thank you very very
much
hashim
i was very lucky to be asked to come and
speak at mit
a couple of years ago and so i had a
chance to spend a bit of time
and see this institution that i'd heard
of all my life
that that had produced
invention which was always my interest
rather than it being about design it was
about ideas that drive
the world forward and so it was
thrilling when
suddenly got out of blue this
notification that i've been
chosen for this award
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
my best tutors
professors were teachers who
didn't try to sort of teach me in a very
uh sort of demonstrative way
actually they were facilitators they
they allowed me
to jump and then
couraged and they facilitated but they
certainly didn't sort of boss you around
the world
the worst ones were the ones who tried
to tell you what to do
and they were the ones that it was
really important to
not take too seriously and i
i think that spirit is matters now more
than ever
when we have access to the world's
information in the way that we do
so i think we're in an interesting time
for for teaching and i think any student
should have a healthy
ability to not not listen
to a tutor
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i wanted to thank the council the
students
and the professors and the mcdermott
prize itself
family for this amazing award
for me it's uh an encouraging thing
it's not something about the past for me
it's a
an encouragement that that people are
interested in the
development work that we've been doing
as a team and
that there's a sort of hand of
friendship reaching out
from a group of people going yeah
yeah can we keep going because i don't
feel i'm any finished
article i feel that we've just got going
as a studio
and as the students at mit must feel
to be at mit is a great sign of
encouragement
and egging on to do things
so i feel egged on by great egg
honors and people who themselves are
being egged on
so i feel less lonely
because sometimes you can feel by
yourself with your team
and to have that hand of friendship
which maybe sounds a bit cheesy but it's
a hand of friendship
from somewhere as incredible as mit
and uh a family that was based on
innovation
like the mcdermott family is is very
exciting and
we're so grateful on speaking on behalf
of my studio
who i'm nothing without my studio
thank you for joining us to celebrate
eugene mcdermott award
and his 2020 recipient thomas hetherweek
i'm deeply proud that mit has this
opportunity
to recognize individuals of such caliber
and vision a special thanks to the
mcdermott family
our gala sponsors the mit council for
the arts
our design students and everyone in our
community
who helps make the arts such a vital
part
of mit
[Music]
you